[Music]
before we get started i just want to
mention that only 22 percent of you are
subscribed so if you enjoy the content
please subscribe to help support the
channel and future content hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing two of the
darkest most powerful wizards that the
wizarding world has ever seen i am of
course talking about voldemort and
grindelwald more specifically i'm going
to be discussing voldemort's wild goose
chase in tracking grindelwald down
and why he did it grindelwald was
famously defeated by dumbledore in 1945
and that news was spread far and wide so
what could grindelwald possibly offer
voldemort why would he still possess a
certain wand voldemort and grindelwald
during their respective pursuits of
power over the course of history were
each able to shake the wizarding world
to its core
however it should be noted that these
men did actually have quite different
objectives grindelwald wanted to obtain
the deathly hallows overthrow the
statute of secrecy and establish
wizarding dominance of the muggle world
with no particular goal to eradicate
muggles or muggle borns
voldemort's objective was much simpler
exterminate and enslave anyone that
either opposed him or didn't come from a
pure magical bloodline
in this way
though they are both undoubtedly evil
voldemort was a lot more sinister and by
the time 1945 rolled around and
grindelwald's own reign of terror was
brought to an end voldemort was just
getting started in his own dark pursuits
the defeat of grindelwald only meant
that there would be a brief poison
tyranny as in 1970 the first wisdom war
officially began
at one stage in voldemort's resurgence
he becomes obsessed with acquiring the
fabled deathly hallow the elder wand
this is because he knows that his
current wand is tied to harry's which
prevents him from killing harry however
he didn't just want any old wand
voldemort had a massive ego he knew that
he was immensely powerful which prompted
him to seek out a wand that he felt was
befitting of him voldemort first becomes
obsessed with the notion of acquiring
this wand after torturing ollivander he
does this after the one that he borrows
from lucius also fails to kill harry
it's at this time that ollivander
discloses a rumor to voldemort which
suggests that grigorovich may have the
elder wand voldemort then tracks down
grugorovich and via torture and
legitimacy figures out that the wand was
stolen by an unidentifiable thief
it's not until voldemort later arrives
at godric's hollow that he finds a
picture of the same thief in bethilda
bagshot's house finally uncovering the
thieves identity gelet grindelwald this
prompts voldemort to visit grindelwald
in nurmengard where he was imprisoned
the cryptic conversation between the two
is shared intermittently during the
malfoy mana scene closing his puffy eyes
he allowed the pain in his scar to
overcome him for a moment wanting to
know what voldemort was doing whether he
knew yet that harry was caught the
emaciated figure stirred beneath its
thin blanket and rolled over towards him
eyes opening in a skull of her face the
frail man sat up great sunken eyes fixed
upon him upon voldemort and then he
smiled
most of his teeth were gone
so you have come i thought you would one
day but your journey was pointless i
never had it you lie as harry spoke his
scar burned worse than ever and for a
few seconds he looked down
not upon the wand maker but on another
man who was just as old just as thin
but laughing scornfully
kill me then voldemort i welcome death
but my death will not bring you what you
seek there is so much you do not
understand
he felt voldemort's fury but as hermione
screamed again he shut it out returning
to the cellar and the horror of his own
present
at once harry scar felt as though it had
split open again his true surroundings
vanished he was voldemort and the
skeletal wizard before him was laughing
toothlessly at him he was enraged at the
summons he felt he had warned them he
had told them to summon him for nothing
less than potter if they were mistaken
kill me then demanded the old man you
will not win you cannot win that wand
will never ever be yours and voldemort's
fury broke a burst of green light filled
the prison room and the frail old body
was lifted from its hard bed and then
fell back lifeless and voldemort
returned to the window his wrath barely
controllable
so after a wild goose chase voldemort
visits grindelwald and ends up killing
him but my question is why did he bother
couldn't he have already reasonably
deduced that grindelwald was no longer
in possession of the wand dumbledore and
grindelwald's jewel was famous he had
never thought to ask dumbledore about
his past no doubt it would have felt
strange impertinent even but after all
it had been common knowledge that
dumbledore had taken part in that
legendary duel with grindelwald and
harry had not thought to ask dumbledore
what that had been like not about any of
his other famous achievements
grindelwald doesn't give him any new
information about the wand and even goes
as far as to lie about ever possessing
it what was the point of that trip to
nurmengard didn't he clue in to the fact
that dumbledore was the one's owner i
think that ultimately what this boils
down to is the fact there's no way that
voldemort could have known whether or
not grindelwald was still master of the
elder wand during his jewel with
dumbledore
he likely deduced that dumbledore had
become the true owner of the wand after
grindelwald's defeat but this was
something that he couldn't be certain of
therefore the most rational course of
action before jet setting straight to
hogwarts would be to visit grindelwald
and confirm his suspicions by visiting
grindelwald who was still very much
alive he could save valuable time and
energy by simply extracting the
information straight from the mouth of a
man that was still living and breathing
to add to this voldemort likely couldn't
resist an opportunity to visit a former
dark lord and assert his superiority
voldemort was more powerful than ever
and grindelwald was a skinny old man
rotting in a prison cell
sure grindelwald was once a powerful and
intimidating figure but those days were
long gone to voldemort who pursued power
above all else this display of dominance
would be a veritable treat it was a
passing of the torch furthermore it's
unlikely that voldemort could have known
about the methodology behind the elder
one's ownership and the fact that
killing is not necessarily required in
order to become its true master he
probably thought that you had to kill in
order to truly own it and when he saw
that grigorovich was still alive he was
at a loss for who the one's true owner
actually was this also likely means that
voldemort didn't purely travel to
nurmegard in order to question
grindelwald but also had intentions to
kill him by murdering grindelwald it
eliminated the possibility of him
somehow being the one's true owner in
the event that he did finally come
across it i always find it interesting
that voldemort being the intelligent
wizard he was got so confused by the
rules surrounding ownership of the elder
wand voldemort was a beacon of knowledge
when it came to all different areas of
magic but it just so happened that one's
law was his achilles heel and that's it
for this video before i go be sure to
also check out my video where i discuss
who is the more powerful dark lord
voldemort or grindelwald if you enjoy
the content please be sure to like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you